i have something i would love feedback
on it's a mashup
time travel horror genre film
our protagonist is seth and he has
created a
time travel app which he calls the time
me up scotty
okay so he's courting investors and
hoping to launch the app but before he
has like this big investor meeting
he you know gets comfortable on a friday
night has a bunch of beers and he starts
playing with the app
and accidentally his own app which he
it's his own creation transports him
to salem massachusetts in the year 1692.
he finds himself in this time travel
that's gone through
in a cell awaiting trial having been
accused of throwing his specter
as witness by disgruntled villagers
meaning that he's
his witnesses saw his image somewhere
else essentially accusing him of
witchcraft
and the horror comes as he cannot prove
his innocence and he's set to be crushed
to death
as punishment so can you tell me
your feelings on my pitch i think it's
kind of cool
um i like it because
it kind of encapsulates what's scary
about the past
is that you can't reason with people
that have a completely different
frame i imagine i mean i've never time
traveled so i can't
speak to that but i just think that it's
interesting
that what makes it scary is that it's an
individual
who is now
living in this reality where there's no
reference point
for anybody else but himself and it's
taking that time travel
genre and then really
making it kind of like a horror movie in
the sense of that
it's kind of like to fish out water but
done in a way where
there's real threats and now you have to
deal with these threats
and i think that is what makes it
interesting
so conceptually i think there's a lot
there but
the device to get
to where it's really getting good
i think that might need a little bit of
work
because i that it seems a little bit
like
there might be more of a streamlined way
so you have a device that brings you
into that
time period but once you're there i'm
really curious about what happens next
i have a little bit of backup but that
was on what happens but
that was my initial pitch so
if would that happen then if i were to
pitch let's say some some individuals
whether it's zoomer in person
would they then those are some of the
notes possibly they would have
what happens next or i wonder if the
frame
is you're talking to a manager
for potential representation and there's
like a networking event
and you're just saying hey i got an idea
i'm just curious
what's the dynamic here then i'll be
able to offer more specific
feedback okay great so we could take
that scenario first and then we could
take another one where i'm pitching
let's say producers so if i'm at a
networking event
and i've i've met a manager and i tell
them my idea
what would the feedback do you think be
i think it's really gonna
depend on the manager's sensibilities so
i mean you know who knows they might
love it or they might hate it you know
so it depends on whether they think they
would want to take on
me as a client or whoever's pitching
this idea and if they like this idea
i don't know if it's about like didn't
really want to take on a potential
client but they might want you to
sign a release for that script and send
over
that material so they can evaluate it
okay
good to know and then i if i'm pitching
a group of let's say five
producers and they've got their poker
champion face on
their shades and their and their hat and
i can't tell what they're thinking
they're emotionless
um what would be some possible
follow-up in the q a well depends i mean
if it's pitching five producers that
feels like it might be like a networking
event that was designed
to expose new writers to producers so
i imagine that they'll be respectful and
they might have questions and just kind
of have a dialogue
it may be different than if you were
working with those producers and then
pitching like a financier so the
producers may be more
animated and more more verbal and
engaged because it's not
about you pitching
somebody that's just going to press a
button and get your movie made they're
gonna first see if
you're somebody that they might want to
collaborate with and just kind of have
like a back and forth
because to get a movie made is a it
takes a long time typically
so they just want to know if they that
you're on the same page
and they like the idea and then they
also might request the script too
what would be some potential questions a
financier might ask
if i pitched this idea i don't think
that like
they're gonna just give you a quick
answer more likely that
they're gonna have a director pitch uh
the project and lead the pitch with a
producer so a writer
at the point where a financier is
involved i mean not say all the time
but once a project's mature enough for
that to be
the case a lot of times the director is
kind of really driving the pitches
to potential financiers and what if i'm
pitching a production company
so i'm pitching them to sell my script
this idea to them
i mean we're talking about like let's
say an environment where it's like a
networking event that some script
organization put on
and you're pitching a production company
i mean you're basically telling them
the log line in a short period of time
what you know and when you think about
the log line
you're thinking about why
is this in differentiating it for this
project from others
so they you're basically trying to sell
them a trailer
to make them want to read the script so
that's kind of the goal
is that you're just saying hey got a
really exciting project
it's a time travel horror film what if
somebody from our time was stuck
in you know the age of witches
and you know when they're doing the
witch hunt what kind of scary things
could happen
during that you know and then that's it
like you just give them
a little pitch less is more if the pitch
goes on too long and you lose their
attention
you just really want to know what the
hook is and then punctuate that
and let them ask questions your goal is
to activate their imagination
not to filibuster for like a long time
about all these ideas
you really want to make sure that it's a
conversation
ultimately and not a monologue so then
they say thank you very much hopefully
they validate my parking
they show me out the door i sit in
traffic for two hours and i wonder
did they like it i think i saw one of
their eyebrows raised when i said this
one thing
i think they liked it or i could tell
this one guy he had his
lips pursed and his his hands cry you
know his he was
the hands crossed a bunch against his
chest and he didn't like it and i'm a
i'm a done deal i'm finished in this
town
i mean you know they're going home you
know they like it if they asked
um for you know your email
so their assistant can email a script
release i mean okay
you know it's not about reading a poker
face at that point it's pretty binary
immediately do they
want to read it and i don't know what
the
in this fictional script event what the
dynamic is and how it's
you know ran but sure most likely
if you pitch to these
participants and they're excited about
it
they're going to get you to most likely
write a write
right on the release that they get
through maybe themselves or their
assistant
and then you send them the script i mean
that's really what it is
and then if they love it then they will
want to work with you and that might be
an option agreement
or a shopping agreement and
some you know lock in the material and
ideally pay you some money
and then bring on the director and the
actors so like it's really the starting
point
of a partnership if somebody you know
reads it and likes it but that's what
but needs to start somewhere so if they
ask for my email
there's a possible second date i should
assume
i mean if they were going to chili's i
mean i think that if they have a script
i mean if they get the script release
and then they get the project you know
once
you've signed it because no one's just
gonna ask for the script
and then if they read it and they like
it
if you have a manager an agent they'll
talk with them and if it's just you
then you talk with the producer
and they might send you deal terms about
locking down the rights
and then you bring in you get a lawyer
and you negotiate a deal and then
if you want to work with the producer
you close out the the paperwork and
now you have a producer who's attached
to the script
how would you shorten this pitch
i think that like that did the way into
the time travel
could be
a little bit streamlined because once we
get
into the new location the new time
period
i think that's when the story becomes
more interesting okay so i just think
that
the the way into the time travel of it
all
you know could need a little work you're
right because i look at
what i have written here that i read to
you and half of this paragraph is all
set up
so okay that's a great point and thank
you for that so
it i should just basically say i mean i
kind of want to make it seem like this
is the guy that his
own creation got him into this kind of
like a frankenstein yeah this is a
monster so what if it's just like
a individual experimenting with
technology
goes wrong and then it becomes the
horror film because now they're
you got them in the wrong place and it's
broken so now it's like survival
yeah i guess i want a part where he
thought he was above his own creation
and that this would never happen to him
but instead his own creation got him
yeah i think that's something that
could be elaborated but you do still
need
that thesis level
pitch where you don't have all these
extra details
because they could kind of once you read
the script they'll
be revealed over time but i think the
key is looking at
the pitch as your trailer
and that trailer instead of like when a
movie is made as it gets you to
pay for a ticket and watch it or
download it at home or whatever
stream it this instead is the trailer is
getting you to read the script
and that's what you're verbalizing